so Russ as I understand it you
originally were auditioning for another
role as well and ended up with riffs
talk about that process it was under
contract at MGM studios at the time and
they let me go an audition for the part
of Tony and I auditioned for that part
and was up for it for as long as the odd
for a long time and luckily I had the
same agent as Robert Wise so I used to
check with him constantly to find out
you know how it was going to do the part
of Tony and I really really wanted to do
that part and he finally said well it's
down between you know you and another
actor and then finally he said a richard
beamer got the part but they've offered
you the part of RIF and I said RIF I
said that that's like a really hardcore
dancing part and I you know and he said
well you want to do it and I said yes so
that's so you were more of a gymnast
though rather than a dancer right it was
a gymnastic and oddly enough when I came
to the to the office to meet to meet
Robert wises and Jerome Robbins when I
came in the first thing that Jerome
Robbins said to me says now Russ you've
tumbled in all these movies of Tom Thumb
and Seven Brides for Seven Brothers
you've done a lot you know you've always
done all this acrobatic dancing but I
have to tell you there's no acrobats in
this there'll be no acrobatic dancing
this is straight dancing and I said okay
I will do my best and so I worked really
hard at it
luckily when mr. Robbins was released
from the movie Tony where Dante took
over and and he he was one of the
assistants and he took over and in the
dance all he said let's put some
tumbling and so I I got to do some
tumbling and not only that but later on
you know this is a kind of a funny story
later on these they had a show it that
you have Pantages and it was also New
York I guess called Jerome Robbins
Broadway and it was a whole bunch of
from different shows that Jerry had done
and one of the numbers was a West Side
Story number and the guy who the dancer
who was playing riff in it in the number
did a flip and I knew that jury had
choreographed it so I couldn't wait to
get backstage afterwards didn't meet him
and say how did you how are you able to
do some flips in that and he said oh
that was part of the audition oh so I
give myself a pat on the back terrific